der nächste Redner jetzt Tino kropaller
von der AFD der Partei
Fraktion her Bundeskanzler sie sprachen
in ihrer Rede von der
deutschlandgeschwindigkeit von der
Geschwindigkeit seit Erfindung der
damflokomotive welche Geschwindigkeit
das ist das Sehen aktuell die Bürger an
ihrer Wahrnehmung ihre Wahrnehmung zur
Situation des Landes geht wirklich an
dem Problem vorbei Herr MZ in ihrer Rede
muss man wirklich sagen sie suchen jetzt
nach den Grünen nach den nächsten
Koalitionspartner soll dann die FDP sein
dieser Schmusekurs eine FDP die dieser
Bundesregierung Handwerk und Mittelstand
verrät diese FDP wird es bald nicht mehr
geben sie ist überflüssig und das werden
die nächsten Landtagswahlen ganz
deutlich zeigen was wir heute und auch
gestern schon von Herrn Linder gehört
haben ist dass diese ampelpolitik
Schuldenpolitik bedeutet und die
Schulden werden eben nicht hier in
Berlin getilgt sondern draußen im Land
von den Bürgern und ampelpolitik ist
auch immer ein Stück postmodern und eben
beliebig so sind die Berechnung der
Neuverschuldung doch recht kreativ auch
heute haben wir das von ihnen gehört her
Bundeskanzler der Bundesfinanzminister
verpackte sein Kunstwerk gestern in sage
und Schreiben 50 Minuten redewer
Redezeit der Deutsche Bundestag ist es
nun dein Haushaltsentwurf verabschieden
soll indem die über 70 Milliarden Euro
in den sogenannten Sondervermögen also
neue Schulden versteckt sind und die
zugewiesenen EU Schulden von 13,2
Milliarden hat ganz beflissentlich unter
den Tisch fallen lassen und das
zusätzlich zur offiziellen
Neuverschuldung von 16 Milliarden Euro
also weit über 100 Milliarden Euro neue
Schulden das zu soliden Finanzen herr
Scholz das ist alles andere als
dies Zitat das Geld fällt doch nicht vom
Himmel ein Zitat von BDI Präsident
ruswurm der Welt am Sonntag zusagte
vielleicht hat Herr Linder deshalb sogar
plötzlich die schulenbremse wieder für
sich und seine entdeckt zu spät meine
Damen und Herren von der FDP 2 Jahre zu
spät in dieser destruktiven
amperegierung hätten sie noch den
meisten wirtschaftlichen Verstand
vielleicht besitzen müssen allerdings
hat das trojanische Pferd in der
Bundesregierung offenbar den Namen Freie
Demokraten in ihm verstecken sich
nämlich die Steigbügelhalter eines
dominanten Staates und sie Herr Linder
haben es im Bundeskabinett zugelassen
dass mitten in der größten Inflation der
letzten Jahre deutsche Firmen ins
Ausland verkauft werden und aus ihrer
Fraktion kamen immer wieder die
kriegslüsternen Töne von Frau Strack
Zimmermann die nun ihr zugfährt für die
anstehenden Wahlen zum Europäischen
Parlament sein soll viel Spaß dazu sie
sind als Politiker und Partei
mittlerweile nur noch unglaubwürdig und
wirklich absolut überflüssig die FDP ist
e genau das was Sie schon immer war der
Pingpongball den die Regierungsparteien
für Koalitionen brauchen und Werte
Kollegen viele von ihnen verbringen seit
Monaten und auch in der Sommerpause Zeit
damit den Bürgern und den Medien zu
erklären warum die Alternative für
Deutschland nicht gut für unser Land
sein soll nur vergessen genau diese
Leute auch dass nicht wir in der
Regierung sind dort sitzen SPD Grüne und
FDP und die CDU findet sich noch immer
in der Opposition nicht ganz zurecht
mauert an seinen brandmäuerchen rum und
auch das fällt als Opposition ett
mittlerweile die CDU aus alle diese
Parteien alle diese Parteien meine Damen
und Herren machen seit über 20
Legislaturperioden im Deutschen
Bundestag Politik sie sollen endlich mal
selbst und ihre politischen Leistung
anfangen zu kritisieren und sich
vielleicht einfach mal fragen warum gibt
es eigentlich eine Alternative für
Deutschland sie sollten endlich die
zollklappen auch absetzen und nicht alle
Anträge der AFD Fraktion ablehnen dann
dann ging es unserem Land wirklich
besser meine Damen und Herren
in der Bevölkerung machen sie sich alle
anscheinend mehr und mehr unglaubwürdig
und das Entdecken offensichtlich immer
mehr Bürger von denen wollen sie zwar
alle wieder gewählt werden Frau esken in
Sachsen 6% die SPD sie sollten ganz
leise sein aber deren Interessen
vertreten wollen sie schon lange nicht
mehr Zitat die Lage wird toxisch sagt
die Präsidentin des VDA hillegard Müller
Antworten der Politik jedoch die die
Interessen der Wirtschaft vertreten
sollten z.B wie unsere Forderung CO2
Abgabe abschaffen Energiesteuern runter
die gibt es nicht Bürokratieabbau ja
dann lassen sie endlich das liefergesetz
kettengesetz Fallen das braucht hier in
diesem Land niemand es geht mittlerweile
auch niemand mehr davon aus und ich im
Übrigen noch nie dass die Grünen mit
Steuergeld überhaupt umgehen können es
hat schon immer Spaß gemacht bei den
Grünen es hat schon immer Spaß gemacht
bei den Grünen das Geld anderer Leute
Gassi zu tragen und wir werden von der
Politik des her hab tagtäglich darin
auch bestätigt eine solche
wirtschaftsfeindliche Politik hat es in
der Bundesrepublik Deutschland noch nie
gegeben meine Damen und
Herren diese grüne Wirtschaftspolitik
funktioniert nur in der gleichfarbigen
Blase einer Partei die daran glaubt das
Klima retten zu können und das hat einen
Preis der für uns alle unbezahlbar wird
meine Damen und Herren allein das
heizungsgesetz GEG kostet unfassbare
2500 Milliarden Euro den und das sind
ihre eigenen Zahlen aus der
Bundesregierung dieses Gesetz braucht
kein Mensch
und die Union soll nicht zu tun in
Sachsen plakatiert sie heizungsverbot
stoppen als wenn Sie dieses Gesetz auch
nicht wöte Frau vondererlein
wahrscheinlich ihre Spitzenkandidatin
von der CDU für die Europawahl plant
sogar ein noch schärferes Gesetz auf
EU-Ebene diese Doppelmoral ist sowas von
unglaubwürdig und das erkennen immer
mehr
Bürger
Zitat die Deindustrialisierung her
Scholz sie haben gesagt die gäbe es
nicht die Deindustrialisierung beginnt
das stellt der Vorstandsvorsitzende des
schomiekonzerns langess Matthias
zachatfest das sind sie und ihrre
Kabinett denus realisieren wollen
prognostizieren meine Kollegen und ich
ihn nachweisig schon seit Monaten Herr
Bundeskanzler und deshalb öffnen sie
wieder wenn sie können bitte beide Augen
und sehen Sie wie die deutsche
Wirtschaft reagiert wie sie abschmt und
kümmer sie sich endlich um das Rückrad
in diesem Land um die deutsche
Wirtschaft laut dem
energiewendebarometer der DIHK erwägen
aktuell
43,3% aller Industrieunternehmen mit
über 300 Beschäftigten eine Verlegung
ihrer Kapazitäten ins Ausland
6,7% planen dies bereits bei 17% laufen
diese Planungen und bei
19,7% sind die Realisierungen schon ab
abgeschlossen damit packen aktuell
36,7% der größten Industriebetriebe ihre
Koffer und das war erst dann für den
Industriestandort das Ende in diesem
Land das ist die Realität der sie sich
komplett verschließen und diese
Bundesregierung hinterlässt eine
traurige Landschaft aus nicht
funktionierenden hochsventionierten
Windrädern eine unsichere
Energieversorgung ohne Grundlast und
eine unendlich hohe Abgabenlast damit
schaffen sie keine Anreize für
wirtschaftliche Unternehmungen oder gute
Lebens
zurerschöpfung beitragen welches
Geschlecht im Personalausweis steht das
können die Bürger entscheiden ob sie
aber in Zukunft noch die Heiz und
Stromkosten bezahlen können oder welche
Heizung sie überhaupt einbauen dürfen
das wissen sie nicht Werte
Bundesregierung ihre politischen
Schwerpunkte sind völlig entrückt und
wie die FAZ unlängst titelte sie sind
absolut
[Applaus]
regierungsunfähig und ich gebe Ihnen mal
ein Beispiel aus der Industrie eine
Gießerei in meinen Wahlkreis hat im Jahr
2016 für eine Kilowattstunde Strom 11,47
Cent gezahlt der Krieg in der Ukraine
und die damit erlassenen unsäglichen
Sanktionen führten zu einem Preisanstieg
um
98% auf
22,37 Cent je Kilowattstunde im Jahr
2022 ab März diesen Jahres muss dieser
Betrieb die nächste Erhöhung um 98%
hinnehmen es sind dann
44,99 Cent die Kilowattstunden
dieser Betrieb her hat eine super CO2
Bilanz er produziert einfach nicht mehr
wie auch der Wagon boniski der Konkurs
angemeldet hat das sind ja bis 180
Arbeitsplätze und nun erwartet wirklich
niemand dass der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister weiß was
darauf folgt ich kann es ihnen sagen
eine Schockstarre aus Kurzarbeit und
Hoffnung darauf dass der Staat seine
Grundaufgaben erfüllt und endlich
Infrastrukturpolitik macht das ist ihre
Aufgabe in diesem Land
mit ihnen und ihrer Ampel Herr
Bundeskanzler hat Deutschland wirklich
fertig sie verspielen auch das dage ich
seit Monaten nicht nur das Vertrauen in
ihre Regierung sondern in die Politik
sie können uns daher dankbar sein dass
wir als einzig wahrneimbare Opposition
Fehler hier in diesem Haus klar benennen
und deshalb die Bürger überhaupt noch an
die wahlurnnen kommen und das obwohl sie
von ihrem Bundeskanzler nicht einmal
mehr ehrliche Worte erwarten
sie haben ihre Klausur in meselberg
angesprochen und dort sagten sie der
Presse die Preise
sinken über welche Preise sprachen sie
da eigentlich die Teuerung spürt bei
einer Inflation von über 6% wirklich
jeder und die nächsten Preissteigerung
sind bereits angekündigt in Gastronomie
in der Automobilindustrie und bei den
Energieerzeugern hier ein Beispiel
kostete eine klimastunde Gas für einen
Privathaushalt in diesem Sommer noch
aktuell 5,38 C wird dies Haushalt ab 1
Oktober diesen Jahres 9,7 Cent die
Kilowattstunde zahlen das eine
Preiserhöhung von
81% aktuell und nebenbei gefragt Herr
Scholz wissen sie inzwischen was ein
Liter Benzin oder Diesel kostet
mittlerweile sind wir wieder bei der
Zwei vor dem Komma ihre Wahrnehmung ist
mittlerweile vollkommen abgekoppelt von
der Lebenswirklichkeit sie leben in
einer Scheinwelt das hat Züge von den
letzten Tagen der Volkskammer in der
DDR
aber sie haben immer neue Vorschläge wie
Sie mehr aus der Wirtschaft pressen
wollen um die Wirren klimawendepläne zu
erfüllen sein sie deshalb auch mal mutig
und informieren Sie die Bürger doch
schon heute dass mit der Verdopplung der
Mautgebühren auf deutschen Autobahn die
ab 2024 kommen soll wieder neue
Preissteigerung zu erwarten sind und
wieder wird die Inflation dadurch
hochgezogen im übrigen ab 3,5 Ton das
betrifft dann auch Kleinunternehmer und
den Mittelstand die wieder darunter
leiden werden es wird wirklich Zeit dass
die Bürger zu ihrem Recht kommen und
dafür garantiert der Sozialstaat der auf
einen Ausgleich zwischen Arm und Reich
zwischen Alt und Jung zielt dieser
Interessenausgleich ist bei ihnen aber
mittlerweile vollkommen aus dem Blick
geraten wer nicht arbeiten möchte
bekommt Ersatzleistung nahezu
bedingungslos und die die Arbeiten
verlieren Monat für Monat am netto wie
die Rentner liebe Kollegen noch steigt
die Lebenserwartung in Deutschland damit
auch der Bedarf an Versorgung finanziell
und medizinisch aber unter
gesundheitminister Lauterbach wurden
Kliniken geschlossen und das schäbige
daran ist noch dass die impfgeschädigten
in diesem Land allein gelassen werden
steht die im Grundgesetz garantierte
unantassbare Würde des Menschen bei
ihnen überhaupt noch im Mittelpunkt für
die eigene für die deutsche Bevölkerung
ihre fahrlässige und verfehlte
Migrationspolitik ist ein weiterer
Bereich mit dem diese Bundesregierung
unser Land spaltet mit dem diese
Bundesregierung wirklich auf Amokfahrt
weiterfährt das straffällig gewordene
Asylbewerber und Migranten konsequent
ausgewiesen werden müssen wäre wirklich
eine erste kleine Maßnahme aber nichts
passiert merken sie nicht wie sie hier
mittlerweile die Kontrolle darüber
verlieren wer in unser Land kommt herte
Migranten täglich an der
deutschpolnischen Grenze diese
Geisterfahrt muss wirklich beendet
werden merken sie nicht wie die Bürger
es leit sind wie mit ihren Steuergeldern
umgegangen werden
wird der vorgelegte Entwurf zum
Bundeshaushalt beweist dass umso mehr
eine wirkliche Veränderung für unsere
Bürger die deutsche Wirtschaft und ein
sveränes Deutschland in Europa kann es
nur mit Neuwahlen geben Herr
Bundeskanzler machen Sie deshalb den Weg
frei die Zeit der Ampel ist abgelaufen
und es geht hier nicht um Parteipolitik
es geht hier sehr wohl um nationale
Kraftanstrengung und die wird es nur mit
der AFD geben es geht um unsere Heimat
in der wir unsere Kinder und Enkelkinder
sehr gern in Sicherheit und Wohlstand
leben möchten daran würden wir als
Alternative für Deutschland in einer
neuen Bundesregierung mit aller Kraft
mit Überzeugung und Glaubwürdigkeit im
Interesse Deutschlands und seiner Bürger
arbeiten vielen
dank der Bundestag debattiert seit heute
morgen hier in der Generaldebatte der
Bundes hat allen beteiligt einen
deutschlandpakt vorgeschlagen es müsse
schneller moderner und sicherer in
diesem Lande zugehen und Tino kopalla
hat jetzt hier noch mal auseinander
genommen dass das Problem vor allem die
Regierung sei hat wirörklich gesagt äh
sie sind wie die Züge der letzten Tage
der Volkskammer in der DDR und hat dann
den kanzleramchluss aufgefordert am
besten wäre es Neuwahlen abzuhalten